you might have seen it we've playing it
here at DW the video of that Indonesian
band 17 being swept off stage and it's
one of the most dramatic to emerge from
the disaster zone it's put a human face
on this unfolding tragedy in a country
that has seen more than its fair share
recently and for more on this band and
its fate we're joined in the studio by
dwz William no igloo Croft thank you for
joining us
so William this band literally swept off
the stage not just them but their their
audience as well we've seen it before
it's been circulating all around the
world this dramatic image that we have
here of this band playing for an
actually a year-end company concert from
the state electric electricity utility
company they're 200 people in attendance
here we have it now they're playing and
then suddenly without warning the wave
sweeps in from behind them and takes
them all out we had the one of the
surviving vocalist members then have
post a very emotional very moving video
to Instagram where he he takes he takes
a moment to remember the people he's
lost the people he's still looking for
we have that as well
we lost our bassist Benny and I wrote
manager Hammond okie and Andy
Andy Hammond and all Jung haven't been
found yet we ask for your prayers
hopefully my wife will be found quickly
I ask your sincere prayer for Bonnie and
Aki thank you it's hard not to be moved
by that and even more so to remember
that that's just his experience in his
band members that story's unfolding
across this region now the utility
company whose concert it was have
confirmed that as many as 29 of its
employees have been killed more than a
dozen are still missing let's not forget
that they're going to make up the over
200 number of people who are reportedly
dead now so what's been the official
reaction right so of course in moments
like these emergency response
organizations and governments come out
the Indonesian president has had this to
tweet he wrote on Twitter earlier today
a deep condolences for the victims of
the tsunami in Panda Guang sarong and
Southland poem last night I have ordered
all relevant government officials to
immediately take emergency action search
and find the victims and treat the
injured that's from the Indonesian
president the German government has
responded to him personally a government
spokesperson speaking for Angela Merkel
said Chancellor Angela Merkel has
expressed to the Indonesian president
her deepest sympathies on behalf of
Germany and the news and images from
Indonesia are shocking and they are
mourning the victims they're mourning
with the families victims and hope that
many more people can still be saved
no William Blu Croft thank you for
joining us from our digital desk